IT'S TIME TO PLAY ON MY WAY TO
STEAL YOUR GIRL.
ON MY WAY TO STEAL YOUR GIRL.
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: HUH? HUH? OH. OH.
SO NICE.
>> OKAY, OKAY, OKAY.
>> Chris: HANDS DOWN ONE OF THE
BEST MEMES ON THE INTERNET IS
"ON MY WAY TO STEAL YOUR GIRL"
PEOPLE POSTING RANDOM PICS
AND THEN WITH BALLER CONFIDENCE
HASHTAGGING IT ON MY WAY TO
STEAL YOUR GIRL, LIKE THIS
PINEAPPLE PLAYA.
ON MY WAY TO STEAL YOUR GIRL!
AND IF THAT FAILS ON MY WAY
TO IMPREGNATE THIS FRUIT.
SO COMEDIANS, WE'RE GOING TO
SHOW YOU SOME PICS WE FOUND
SEARCHING ON MY WAY TO STEAL
YOUR GIRL AND FOR 250 POINTS,
YOU GIVE US AN ALTERNATIVE THING
THAT THEY'RE ON THEIR WAY TO DO.
FIRST ONE, FIRST ONE, THIS CAKE
BOSS.
WHERE'S HE OFF TO, JESSICA.
>> ON MY WAY TO GIVE YO' GIRL
TYPE 2 DIABETES.
>> Chris: YES.
POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THIS MACK ON
MACKERELS.
ON MY WAY TO --
PAUL FEIG.
>> ON MY WAY TO TOTALLY RUIN
BATMAN VERSUS SUPERMAN.
>> Chris: YES.
WELL DONE.
THE GAUNTLET IS LAID.
YOU OF ALL PEOPLE TAKING SUCH A
ABUSE! THEY'RE JUST SPINNING--
>> I AM GOING ALL OVER MY FELLOW
DIRECTORS.
>> Chris: I LOVED IT EARLIER
WHEN HE HAD A BONER IN THE
LOUNGE CHAIR.
>> IT'S MOVED TO HIS CALF
APPARENTLY.
>> Chris: NEXT ONE, ON MY WAY TO
STEAL YOUR GIRL.
YES, JESSICA.
>> ON MY WAY TO MAKE A ROOM FULL
OF VAGINAS FEEL DRYER THAN
THEY EVER HAVE BEEN.
>> Chris: POINTS.
NEXT ONE, THIS TOP GUNNER, THIS
TOP GUNNER -- ON MY WAY TO STEAL
YOUR GIRL.
JAMIE.
>> ON MY WAY TO MY DIVORCE
PROCEEDINGS.
>> Chris: PAUL.
>> ON MY WAY TO A SUPER
DISHONORABLE DISCHARGE.
>> Chris: YES.
>> ON THIS LADY'S LEG.
THERE YOU GO, POINTS, POINTS.
>> AY-OH!
>> Chris: I LIKE THAT THE BOW
STARTED BEFORE YOU FINSIHED
THE JOKE.
>> YOU GOTT TAKE IS WHERE YOU
CAN GET IT.
>> Chris: LAST ONE, LAST ONE.
ON MY WAAAYYY TO SALE YOUR GIRL.
JESSICA.
>> ON MY WAY TO BECOMING
MEATBALLS AT IKEA.
>> Chris: YES.